trevor cahill starts on the mound and
hits ninth just one in four this year
with a six point seven five era for
castiano's the right-handed hitter
nine home runs 22 runs batted in
the 1-2 pitch and a roller to third up
with it gonzales throws across for the
out three ground ball outs for trevor
cahill
and after a half inning it's the reds
nothing the pirates are coming to bat
sonny gray makes a start today for
cincinnati and it was right here at pnc
park where he made his major league
debut on july 10th 2013. i tom stands in
to get the game started for pittsburgh
here's the one-two pitch
and strike three called and now here is
the aforementioned gregory polanco
polanco hitting just 198 but he does
provide a little power in the middle of
this lineup he does have three home runs
this year five driven in
from the belt the one-two pitch
gonna miss there's the elevated fastball
and he blew it by polanco he's down on
strikes gray with two punch outs here in
the first inning pirates get a single
but strand him at second we head to the
second inning trevor cahill will face
mike mustakis the cleanup hitter
now the 01 pitch and mustache drills
this deep to the right center field
alley hit a ton and gone way out of here
to right center field just to the left
of the 375 sign
and mike mustakis
puts the reds on top one to nothing with
his fourth home run of the year
now kyle farmer who is
two for seven in the series
falls in the dirt swung on and missed
for the strikeout
and we'll go to the bottom of the second
inning it's now the reds one pirates
nothing here is wilmer defoe
bare hand santel
gets it done
well that looked like a hit all the way
right there senzel just makes a
superlative play
now the catcher michael perez with a 129
average up there one home run three rbis
for perez here's the payoff pitch
strike three called got him looking
fastball well thrown down at the knees
and he locks up perez third strikeout
for sonny gray and that's a big out
because now he gets the pitcher trevor
cahill well so now it's trevor cahill
the pirates pitcher
at the plate
the 3-2 cahill grounds it weakly to
first mustachus will handle it and take
it himself to the bag and that will end
the pirate threat in the second and
philip evans will step to the plate
swing and a miss a slider there and down
goes evans one down or two down
sonny gray with his fourth strikeout
here's polanco
strikeout victim his first time up
two bull two strike count newman off the
bag at second gray checks him once twice
and there goes newman the third swing
and a miss there's the high heater
and polanco misses it yet again so
back-to-back strikeouts with a runner
standing in second for sonny gray
and he is scoreless through three reds
lead one-nothing fourth inning coming up
here is the number eight hitter michael
perez the pirate catcher
up the middle caught by farmer
sensational play
owen won the count on cahill
first and second two outs camel at first
base defoe at second two away one
nothing reds bottom of the fourth inning
in pittsburgh
red's going for a series victory here's
the pitch
and there's a fly ball center field
right center coming over is the center
fielder naquin and it's the right
fielder costiano's cutting in front to
make the catch the two clip their feet
stay upright
but a minor collision everybody seems to
be okay the inning is over the reds get
the final out the pirates strand two and
we head to the fifth
polanco has struck out twice
gregory polanco at the plate the pitch
line drive right field base hit
ties the game at one gregory polanco
rips it into right scores newman evans
to second it's 1-1 he turned on a
fastball good fastball too yeah gray's
not a really hard thrower that one was
94.
seven hits for the pirates and now
they're checking on
evans
yeah evans uh tarek brock is talking to
him philip evans
as derek shelton comes out
and they're gonna take him out of the
ball game shelton
meets evans over there by the first base
bag
and he'll escort philip evans back
off the field toward the third base
dugout
so the game is tied at one and now eric
gonzalez will be the hitter here's the
2-2 pitch to gonzalez ground ball right
at short farmer coming home and now
they've got the runner at third in a
rundown stevenson will tag out frazier
gonzalez will reach on the fielder's
choice it goes six to two at home
here's wilmer depot
low wide stance for defoe he's choked up
on the bat the one-two pitch swing gonna
miss he strikes him out with a breaking
ball in the dirt and down on strikes
wilmer defoe a huge out for tj entone
and the reds lefty hitting shogo akiyama
a lefty hitter to bat against clay
holmes with a 2-0 count the pitch
bouncer back to holmes
and he'll underhand toss to first for
the final out
head to the bottom of the sixth inning
reds won pirates one
senzelle 0 for three this afternoon
another 2-2 offering
and hit hard toward right center field
and over is polanco and polanco is there
to make the catch
chasing shreve it's a strikeout and a
flyout
and gets us to the seventh inning
stretch
and here is eugenio suarez one out of
three in this game
here's the pitch
swing and a foul tip and a strikeout
david bednar
winker's about as locked in as they come
he does have a base hit today
hard on the ground through the whole
base hit
centel giving the wave they test gavel
from left to throw in no chance
centel dances across the dish and the
reds take the lead on contact from jesse
winker reds two pirates one
here's juarez
the 1-0 pitch and he hammers it to left
center field it's going to go all the
way to the wall mustache on his horse
rounding third winker scores castiano
scores mustaches in
and the reds
have taken
a five
one lead how about that and how about a
eugenio suarez
a big swing of the bat for the big fella
that brings up kyle farmer
bouncing ball right at the shortstop
newman throws on to first to retire the
side
but the reds score four and head to the
bottom of the 10th cincinnati five
pittsburgh one and now frazier the last
man standing who remember entered today
riding the best hitting streak in
baseball
tied for the best of his career
12 in a row
he's had one at bat
struck out looking in the seventh
hambury ready his payoff
hard on the ground
suarez
ball game reds